wow that was something right there rod
that was von miller it's trade deadline
day right now in the nfl you just saw
vaughn's emotions i'll be honest with
you i hadn't seen that clip i've seen a
few clips of him talking the media since
the trade but he was emotional right
there wasn't he that was really hitting
him what'd you think of the trade and
then the response from vaughn
well well i'ma go with the response
first i mean obviously um i was a free
agent and i ended up going to the
patriots and when you change teams it
almost feels like it's new it's fresh
it's something different but once you
get there you go from a losing situation
to a winning situation i know he's very
emotional right now but it's the best
thing that could happen to your football
life because it gives you a new lease on
life it gives you an opportunity to to
come to work and know that you're you
have a chance to go to the playoffs and
we know the rams are going to the
playoffs and that the rams are going to
be competing late into january
but yeah man it's he's a first ballot
hall of famer he did an excellent job
when he was in denver had a lot of
respect for john elway giving him that
opportunity and i'm just happy for von
miller man this is this guy is a first
ballot hall of famer he still has that
explosive first step
he plays the run he holds that edge and
he's still a player and sometimes when
you've been in the situation for so long
and you continue to get hurt then you
come out of there and you go into
another situation maybe this would help
with all the little injuries and
everything but i'm happy for vaughn he's
going to be outstanding and he's going
to help take a lot of pressure off of
jalen ramsey and leonard floyd and aaron
donald i think this was a home run for
the rams
yeah home run for the rams home run for
vaughn like i expected to see tears of
joy when i first heard the news now he's
a denver legend and i think i had to
spend the day reminding myself of that
and i think he was really happy there
he's somebody that i could see maybe
even after his career returning or
always having a house in denver just
because of what that town means to him
what he was able to accomplish in that
time and i think it feels like home to
him every time i've been around him he
seems to really be drawn to denver but
man to be able to go to la to join this
team be able to maybe play a home super
bowl right now and i just think for a
veteran at this point in his career
sometimes it's just new life you know
what i mean it just gives you new energy
you're highly motivated again you feel
like you're chasing super bowls you get
this second chapter of his career
and i think it's coming at the perfect
time now from the rams standpoint this
is a group rod that is just going all
chips center of the table
right here right now we don't care about
the future we don't care about drafts
coming up they are trying to win in this
super bowl window with donald with
ramsey with von miller with floyd with
all that talent offensively and of
course with stafford i think they're
just saying this is our shot man we're
just going all after it forget about any
of the future we're going right now
we'll see what happens but this has kind
of been the ram strategy ever since 2017
when mcvay took over
yeah and i think it's smart because i
mean you gotta you gotta go make that
run before aaron donald starts getting
up into his 30s and then you get jalen
ramsey if he gets injured or something
like that so them putting all the chips
in and we've seen them pay a lot of guys
whether it was brandon cooks they paid a
lot of people jared goff they played a
lot of the wrong people but i think in
this situation for von miller i think he
comes in a situation where he doesn't
necessarily have to be a man he can just
be a contributor on the defense aaron
donald's still a stud they got other
really good players around them that's
going to help the secondary and the
corners like i said this is a slam dunk
for the um for the rams going out and
getting a guy of this caliber at this
point in time of his career
it is it is especially when you have
multiple pass rushers and you got to
worry about multiple guys that can get
after the pass or you start getting into
teams like the bucks or maybe it's you
know green bay down the line that's who
they're thinking about right now with
this move and i think it will work out
just go through some of these trades
though the brandon cooks trade the sami
watkins trade they've made the marcus
peters trade akeeb talib dante fowler jr
sony michelle jalen ramsey matthew
stafford that is a lot of blockbuster
trades that they've been playing and
it's just because they're trying to be
so aggressive out there right now we'll
see what comes but how about melvin
ingram he's another pass rusher goes to
pittsburgh about his 10th year in the
league now a long career with the
chargers he was in pittsburgh and then
quickly makes his way to kansas city
what'd you think of that move as well
for the chiefs
i was actually kind of surprised because
i know alex high smith he's playing he's
playing solid football but don't you
want as many pass rushers as possible
especially with tj watt and as hard as
he plays i just i don't know if i would
have let him go i maybe he wasn't
playing well i'm not 100 sure of that
but at the end of the day man if i got
an extra pass rusher i'm trying to do my
best to keep him and hold on to my pass
rushers especially going into the winter
months
rod let's listen to mike tomlin here was
some coach tomlin sound today after the
trade deadline after the move
what the team needs is first and
foremost um
and that's just how it goes that's the
component of
team sport and football in particular um
that's always the first and foremost but
from a team perspective also
it's better to have volunteers as
opposed to hostages and so that's good
for the team as well
oh so i get it jack i get it so melvin
wasn't happy there and he had attitude
and he wasn't probably practicing hard i
get it now okay thank you to mike tomlin
for giving me that
there's always another layer to the
story isn't there there's always another
level another layer i was interested
because he's been playing well third on
the entire team and pressures behind
only cam hayward and t.j watt that's
pretty good company second on the team
or actually he's tied for the team lead
with tj watt when it comes to
quarterback hits quarterback hurries he
has 11 that's second on the team so he's
10 years in he's a veteran guy and i
guess he wasn't completely happy with
his role but production's still there
and i just look at how desperate the
kansas city chiefs have been defensively
they're getting no pass rush there's
just been really nothing happening
that's good defensively for kansas city
they're just looking for any kind of a
spark as they go into this really tough
stretch of their schedule so it makes a
lot of sense for them but anybody with a
bad attitude i do worry about especially
when you're playing winning football
it's been a pretty good turnaround for
the pittsburgh steelers to imagine that
ingram doesn't want to be there for it
pretty strange to me hearing that
comment right there from tomlin
yeah but also you think about it when
you bring in a veteran player you want
that player to help the locker room you
don't want that player taken away from
the locker room a lot of those young
guys have respect for melvin ingram so
if he says something they listen and if
you know that as a head coach if you
know you have a disgruntled veteran in
there and he's not happy whether it's
with his plan time the fact that he's
not starting then he starts talking he
knows that's the quickest way to have
dissension in your locker room and i
think he was smart
now that i know that and i've heard that
clip i think it was a smart move getting
rid of him
rod if his attitude is right or if his
attitude perhaps becomes right how good
of a move is this for kansas city
defensively on the football field
well you know he's going to be motivated
he's still in the afc west he played
with the chargers for a whole bunch of
years and now he's he understands that
frank clark is always hurt he
understands that chris jones he's been
through some injuries so this is a guy
that you could plug on the left side the
right side he'll get after the
quarterback he's going to play hard he's
a tough guy he's not the same player
that he was three four years ago but
he's still a very solid veteran that you
can put um that you can bring in the
most important thing is his attitude
so those are kind of the headliners
right there the one man who was not on
the move deshawn watson staying put with
the texans it's somewhere between
what other teams are willing to trade to
get him what the texans are willing to
accept to move him so he is going to
stay put for the time being what would
you be willing to give up there's
obviously so much uncertainty what would
you be willing to give up if you're one
of these other 31 teams to get watson on
your team
yeah the texans aren't a tough situation
because they have a guy that no one
knows exactly what's going to happen to
them so if they're expecting a bunch of
first round picks and second round picks
is not going to happen they're not gonna
do it if i'm a general manager i might
think about giving up maybe a second
round pick maybe a fourth round pick and
a player to be named but outside of that
you have to still pay his salary you
still have to deal with all the
consequences that come with the mistakes
that he made and you just don't know
what the league is going to do do they
spend suspend them six games do they
suspend them eight games you don't know
if they're going to suspend them the
entire season you just don't know
in miami puts themselves in an
interesting position now where it really
feels like they don't trust tua just
given that they were interested in this
situation it's hor i don't think they do
either it's horrible pr for them just
given that they were willing to glance
and inquire about making this deal and
they ultimately end up doing absolutely
nothing so it's just a weird situation
for miami as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports